bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono famiglie oggi siamo
tornati su detroit perché vi è piaciuto
tantissimo il primo episodio e ho deciso
di fare il secondo che è l'ultimo che
posso fare senza poi andare a
spoilerarvi quello che il gioco quindi
vai col secondo episodio che non c'entra
se cavo il primo prefiggo lo stesso
buona visione
[Musica]
cosa ho fatto scusate non volevo una
portiera doveva aprire manco quello
partiamo da dio non ci sei stata per due
settimane c'è un casino
devi pulire casa da fare le lavatrici
cucinare e occuparti della sai calmo
porca [ __ ] dove cazzo finita cosa
molto ma family friendly in sto gioco lo
sanno cos'è
eccoti qui le yaris occupati di lei
compiti bagno tutte quelle cazzate
capito sito comincia a sistemare qui poi
vai di sopra
io non so tenere a posto neanche la mia
di casa però va bene si si sono allora
le scovare iniziamo a mettere a posto le
cagate che quell'uomo fa ad esempio
lasciare le cose in cucina che è
comunque come faccio io è se guardate
casa mia uguale filippino simulator 2018
ecco mia mamma sarebbe straniera di
vedermi giocare a questo gioco non a
tutti gli altri ma questo se questi sono
i miei traguardi da youtuber nel massimo
della mia vita lo stesso 5 milioni di
iscritti meritatissimi con il lavaggio
dei piatti di
todd ciao amici posso andare a prenderla
dai basta smettere le varie piante lei
soltanto che schifo ma basta me li devo
levare tutti sta un po fino a domani o
vaghe in video di youtube dieci minuti
monetizzi bene poi basse ma le ragazzine
ogni sopra vela camera di ellis
abbiamo sbloccato la scatola dei misteri
incredibili tipo quella di affari tuoi
gabry e incasina non mi ricordo bene
cosa c'era dentro la scatola sai c'è la
voce aperta però mi per view
ah sì c'era la foto di sua mamma
[Musica]
è un quadrifoglio
ma fatta smontargli così
com'è possibile
già mi spiego in realtà
[Musica]
io ero loro android e poi mi è successo
qualcosa mi hanno riportata qui dopo che
mi hanno resettato la memoria perché ero
il tipo smonterò a pezzi però mi sa che
mi ha smontato lui c'è e ovvio che mi
hanno smontato
accendi la luce ok
servi alice todd io a farmi servire la
bambina vita perde il lavoro per colpa
degli androidi e quando mi serve
qualcuno che sistemi questo accesso di
casa che cosa faccio è solo lei sa su un
cazzo di android è però non si stancano
ma sono mai tristi che hai da guardare
non è la vita che sogna mia
credi forse che sia facile forse credi
che è colpa mia se viviamo in questa
fogna
beh è colpa mia se quella [ __ ] di tua
madra se n'è andata beh anche questo
dovresti smettere di farti dott
a volte mi fa davvero paura la stronza
se ne va senza dire una parola
la stronza mila camper un'impiegata del
cazzo è tutta colpa tua
va bene è tutta colpa tua casa
torna qui torna qui torna qui subito
tu resta lì non provare a muoverti conti
con ciò peggio dell'altra volta
adesso c'è la parte bruttissima dove non
posso muovermi per cui mi ha dato
l'ordine di non muovermi è invece posso
rompere la barriera che è quello che fa
diventare degli androidi vedevi anti c'è
veramente quelli che non rispettano gli
ordini e io te lo meno manco goku super
sayan bravissimo in teoria dovremmo fare
così
poi però devo andare dice protegge risi
infatti di andare lì per proteggere la
bambina
proverò a fare diversamente dalla prima
volta la prima volta sono riuscito
subito a scappare
adesso non lo so cipro prova a fare
diversamente vedere se riesco
[Musica]
è tranquilla ci sono io no tranquilla
ceva via o di romperà come l'ultima
volta
chiuditi dentro
proverò cercando
ecco non avevo fatto così la prima volta
non so come andrà adesso non ho idea da
cui non so niente devo fare qualcosa
trovavo cosa per difenderti perfetto
mena iene
che cazzo ci fai qui teme noti dalle
palle no non le farei del male fanno
davvero sempre avere un problema
ma lo si spera
madonna che sono aggressivo proprio
fa
ma
dai una botta pure tu
cavalca che sarà un altro di miccoli
[ __ ]
lui la vela tutto bene agli fortissimo
mica sta seccando tutto ragazzo non lo
batto adesso non so ma che poi io
vecchietta
ha già fatto malissimo qua
stare
e fai come ti dico
sì ma meno anche tu fa qualcosa o
minchia ci voleva tanto gli anni anice
corri corri veloce massima veloce
scappa scappa che guardi il papa
capo
tornate qui
lo cammina
con il giardino non ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato non dovevo fare questo e anche
male
se volevi
no ho sbagliato stavolta
dario azzeccato quasi tutto
[Musica]
che ansia madonna
cavalca scavalca veloce però c'è chi vai
vai vai bravissimi ma che cazzo è un
deficiente via via via pigna l'autobus
[Musica]
madonna se fosse successo tipo a casa
mia ero morto perché l'autobus non passa
mai
sempre in ritardo un casino vescovi non
era andata così la prima volta che l'ho
fatto io però me la sono cavata lo
stesso visto che bravo fi che ti do la
mano
[Musica]
e quindi ragazzi quest'anno secondo
episodio di detroit spero che vi sia
piaciuto cosi mi piace anche vari social
con descrizione si era stata quesiti
schierate ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]